the angry president trump that we saw in
phoenix tuesday night was nowhere to be
seen in reno nevada yesterday instead he
called for unity and healing he will
need a lot of that to push his agenda on
capitol hill the president is not
getting along with senate republican
leader mitch mcconnell and house speaker
paul ryan dismissed his threat to shut
down the government over a planned
border wall with mexico margaret brennan
is at the white house where the
president returned last night margaret
good morning
good morning president trump promised
that americans would not pay for the
border wall now he's threatening a
government shutdown if taxpayers do not
fund it he's at odds with his republican
allies and today the president will meet
with his legislative affairs team to try
to break the impasse
it is time to heal the wounds that
divide us president trump struck a
conciliatory tone in his remarks
wednesday to the american legion we have
no division
too deep for us to heal
and there is no enemy
too strong
for us to overcome
strikingly different from the fiery
speech mr trump delivered the night
before at a campaign-style rally in
phoenix when he threatened to shut down
the government the obstructionist
democrats would like us not to do it but
believe me we have to close down our
government we're building that wall that
shutdown mr trump said depends on
whether the republican-controlled
congress funds his proposed border wall
the government will run out of money
october first if no new spending bills
are approved house speaker paul ryan i
don't think
anyone is interested in having a
shutdown i don't think it's in our
interest to do so but the president
seems to be picking fights with
republicans including senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell who the president
needs to quarterback his legislative
agenda both tried to paper over their
rocky relationship in dueling statements
on wednesday claiming they remain united
but on twitter mr trump again urged
mcconnell to ditch senate filibuster
rules to help sideline democrats
something mcconnell has said is off the
table and the president is trying to
unseat republicans who challenge his
agenda backstage before the phoenix
rally mr trump met with two of the
prospective candidates trying to defeat
arizona senator jeff flake who he called
weak
in tweets this morning the president is
laying blame on mcconnell and ryan for a
potential debt ceiling crisis he says
they refused his request to attach a
debt ceiling increase to a recently
passed and popular v.a bill now they'll
have to pass a separate law to pay
america's bills and avoid a financial
crisis
the plot thickens margaret thank you